so Lucy COEs woke up in Sikkim I've got
a baby this lately it's been three to
four hours not having that paper changes
everything
[Music]
who's gonna want to wake up at 3:30 in
the morning I got a full-time job and a
voluntary the morning before work drop
the refugee to the airport and do this
over again every day Monday to Sunday
just barely woke up from a nap I'm going
to work right now
[Music]
I live in Horace but I cross every day
because I'm studying my major of
journalism and the University of Texas
at El Paso if president um they decide
to close the border I think it would
affect a lot this community I'm not
gonna be able to finish my study I
usually drive every day back and forth
to go to school there's more migrants
and with President Trump saying that he
was gonna close the border and
everything being like I'm certain when
he started taking some of the CBP's away
for the Lions that's when we really
started to see a difference we're the
bridge I'm doing the line to trust to
opacity lately it's been three to four
hours two hours cuatro horas necessary
Caliente Michelle carro de Mesilla
contaminatio on was migrants given in
the tool the officers our work here at
the border they're being transferred to
the other part of country suddenly see
like this change in the water we
basically receive text from eyes letting
us know how many refugees are gonna be
released
like today they were released 721 we
received daily sixty refugees they're
either sick due to the fact that they're
in a place that is kind of cold running
fevers a cold or they have stomach
problems from autumn Allah under us I'll
solve the door people that they come
here to our church with legal documents
from immigration where they've been
through a process to make sure that
they're not criminals but they could
come into the state temporarily for they
could reach their family members
Afghanistan is a beautiful ya know
estamos en una albergue a candle okay
baby no sayin la cárcel activity Moody
yellows Darren ropa mucho vania no sin
ropa el desayuno Alma's y la cena pro se
in Mira uno que que como se a a las
siete la mañana a la puerta y CR a las
cinco ayer que intro oh I see no per se
que fuera imagine okay add a ver peligro
mi sobrina tiene Doce de que no Mira
Susie ho video or que se los lovara
pasamos hacia el otro lado yeah no
estaba esperando los de la migra
no se Perrin come is abrino me here okay
prácticamente over near souls token
wedding band b lo que VA la Haine ke
quelled se dieron Sekar knows a todos
Amanda knows Baraka
currently I'm working for a border scene
border scene allows you to do stories
either in Spanish or in English we get
to see like both sides of the border you
have been here living like 21 years and
I've never seen so many immigrants
coming a lot of people here in the
community especially from parties are a
little bit more aggressive to where the
immigrants because they're disrupting
like the city because we don't have the
infrastructure to kind of support the
amount of people that's coming in I
think that when someone like migrates
there needs to be something really bad
happening back home because of the
travel they do they don't have water
there's a lot of heat they need to walk
for days for weeks for months not having
that paper changes everything
apparently in the El Paso sector we are
averaging approximately 700 individuals
being detained on a daily basis did they
walk up to you
Guatemala Tamir stairs papa any juntos
whatta mala sanssouci cause they just
crossed and turned himself into this
Border Patrol agents father daughter
father sign our facilities Border Patrol
we were never built to house family
units as we're seeing now so it's a huge
challenge for us not only is in our
facilities but as far as the agents and
the supplies and the care my name is
Cynthia bomba and I work as the advocacy
manager at the border right Center we
simply walk across to Cuates to Mexico
and observe what is happening are are
they're my migrants or asylum seekers
arriving and are being told to turn away
who is telling them what are they being
told this is a new stretch of the border
wall that was funding during Trump
administration
young migrant got up to present herself
at a port of entry and was told by a CBP
official that she needed to go back
the Mexican angel and get herself on a
list she was really confusing last I saw
a young boy who showed out by himself to
to request asylum and what is unlawful
is house EVP standing in the middle of
the international bridges right on the
international line and turning away of
silent seekers
[Music]
a key venimos cuando ASEA terminado todo
el proceso de inmigración está una dessa
non de terras NCT sect angle proceso
euro puede peligro muna quartet dentro
de Estados Unidos toss kasi tres dias
Ambani artisan fuertes APR la boca todos
los que passaa Mo's pora he knows infer
Mambo's Bermejo term en el suelo yost
interior may culpable a kappa s AKA
ottokar PVA's Horita no tiene una escena
como como de Raya by Castilla de cerdo
muy Rico Dec ahmo's Tia tanto tiempo no
comer arose no fregoli token carne me
familia sino SOTA mucho por la violencia
me Viacom event or Archon mini epic Enya
dekat Rowan itõs in Ventura a Hemi Papa
mama son personas de la tercera yo see
Hamas mi país para hacer Mira trabaja
para most Italian port on teh me toka
ear porque Javier no del durrës Tomo
repress awliyas contra me Saeki Stojko
me ho d'etre Serrano's algunas personas
nose Miren Contras Tessa otra cosa bucho
y en fada
[Music]
numero Quatro was the personís on those
okay
[Music]
I want to help the people off because
when ice one of the things that I see
things that I hear from them is like I
don't like it they go in different
places all the parents they go to Miami
New York Boston Kansas City Dallas all
the Pens you know one of the family
leave I don't know when the job will in
I'll be there into it they're you know
I'm to it finish you know and to be
honest I don't know what's the day could
take a year two years I'm not sure
[Music]